good evening and welcome to a special
edition of tucker carlson tonight it was
a year ago
this week that nancy pelosi was walking
the streets of san francisco's chinatown
without any concern whatsoever for her
personal safety
nancy pelosi's face was stark naked she
wasn't wearing a mask
neither were the dozens of people who
surrounded her a local cbs affiliate was
on the scene following all of it
but even the coronavirus was already
spreading all over the world in places
like france and south korea and we now
know
here in the u.s cbs didn't suggest that
anything was amiss they didn't report
that nancy pelosi was a walking
biohazard or a super spreader
and why would they think that just days
earlier tony
fauci had gone on television and
promised americans that the risk of
coronavirus infection in this country
was quote minuscule so if tony fauci's
word meant anything at the time people
thought that it did
nancy pelosi's walk around chinatown
wasn't alarming it was
heroic as one cbs news reporter put it
nancy pelosi was a walking one-woman
tourist attraction on a mission to
defeat a pathogen
far more insidious than the coronavirus
nancy pelosi was in chinatown to defeat
racism against asian americans plus
yourself is explicit on that point quote
we want to say to people come to
chinatown here we are
we're careful we're safe come join us in
other words if you're worried about
catching the virus
by gathering in a big crowd in chinatown
that means you're a white supremacist
so one year after that remarkable day
what have we learned
well for one thing we know that despite
her very best efforts nancy pelosi did
not
succeed in extinguishing anti-racism
against racism against asians in san
francisco
in fact a year later violence against
asian americans in san francisco is at
the highest rate ever
so if you're a reasonable person you
might call for an investigation into
this what's causing these attacks how
can we stop them
but if you tune in to cnn or msnbc you
already know why they're happening
donald trump yes the great orange menace
may
not be in the white house anymore he may
not have gotten any
votes at all in san francisco but don't
be fooled donald trump
is the reason this is happening and that
sends a larger message to the rest of us
from our political class and their
servants in the media
never blame the people in charge
that's a familiar refrain we've heard it
a lot over the last 12 months and for
the most part
it has worked propaganda usually does
and that's why we're going to spend the
next hour
highlighting the politicians and the
bureaucrats who have not been held
accountable for what they did to this
country during the pandemic
they've ruined lives they've destroyed
businesses they cause people to die
but if you confront them on any of these
questions they will tell you reflexively
it's someone else's fault no single
politician has used this tactic more
often or more shamelessly
as the governor of new york state andrew
cuomo cuomo accepted an emmy award last
year for performances like these when
the pandemic was beginning
last spring strategy
plan of action all along step one
flatten the curve
in other words we're all talking about
this curve flatten the curve
we're trying to flatten the curve and we
have to flatten the curve
we reduce the rate we so-called flatten
the curve
flatten the curve flatten the curve
flatten the curve we did it we flattened
the curve
boy that's a great slogan what does it
mean exactly what is flattening the
curve well
not many people bothered to ask that
question for new yorkers last year
flattened the curve became the new
version of 15 days to slow the spread
just a series of words deranged in order
so politicians can repeat them over and
over to convey the impression they were
in charge
and doing something to fix the problem
in reality andrew cuomo spent most of
his time sitting for interviews with his
brother over on cnn
and having staffers write a book under
his name that book was called
american crisis lessons leadership from
the covid19 pandemic
when we took a look at some of the top
customer reviews for the book on
amazon.com people actually read it
here's the top review right now quote a
heartfelt and caring look at how it
feels to murder people through
bureaucratic ineptitude
here's the next review on amazon.com at
the moment quote
governor cuomo's self-serving book
raises embarrassing questions
politicians being human make mistakes
andrew cuomo as scientists agree made a
serious error that led to thousands of
unnecessary tragic deaths in nursing
homes
shouldn't a politician like cuomo have a
moral obligation to admit his error
even as in this case it is likely to
lead him losing his position his chance
to be president of the united states and
lawsuits
what's a good question doesn't he have a
moral obligation to do that
as that reviewer noted in march of last
year andrew cuomo ordered nursing homes
in the state to admit
patients who had tested positive for the
coronavirus
then cuomo's administration hid the
total number of nursing home
deaths that resulted from that order
we're not speculating about that one of
his staffers admitted they did it but
andrew cuomo himself still has not
acknowledged that he did this or any
wrongdoing whatsoever
instead last week he blamed the people
who work in nursing homes
kovid did not get into the nursing homes
by people coming from hospitals covert
got into the nursing homes
by staff walking into the nursing home
so case closed i am not responsible for
the 11 000 nursing home deaths in new
york or the coordinated effort to cover
up those deaths
you know who's responsible the nurses
the receptionist making 35 grand a year
they must suffer
their lives must be ruined so that
andrew cuomo can keep his job and his
emmy award
but we don't mean to single out andrew
cuomo he's not the only incompetent
politician who needs to save face and
will lie and hurt others in order to do
it
our public health experts are scrambling
to avoid humiliation too
and there's a lot of it waiting for them
and if that means isolating the most
vulnerable members of our society even
more than they've already been isolated
then that's the cost it's collateral
damage it's a price they're willing to
pay
because they don't pay it this is a real
article published by nbc news earlier
this month it lays out word for word
we're reading from it verbatim quote
after grandparents or older parents
receive the coronavirus vaccine can you
visit them
the answer is likely no but it depends
one expert from northwestern university
said essentially
nothing changes after the vaccine end
quote again
nothing changes after the vaccine
it's hard to believe they're saying this
and it's not just one so-called expert
from northwestern saying it
tony fauci himself is saying it too
quote until we have the overwhelming
majority of people vaccinated
and the level of virus is very low fauci
said
this month you probably shouldn't visit
your grandparents without your mask on
it's just too early
to be doing something that reckless
human contact with the ones you love
most
breaking people out of their prisons of
solitude don't dare
even after the vaccine tony fatchi wants
to take it slow on the other hand fauci
is still capable of acting very very
quickly as long as the right interests
are involved as long as he's profiting
from it or his allies are
we'll give you one of many examples tony
fatchi has already decided without any
hesitation whatsoever
that the world health organization
deserves billions
of your money right away u.s tax dollars
now the world health organization is the
group that could have warned the rest of
the world about the pandemic
could have saved lives but chose instead
to repeat chinese propaganda instead
your grandmother can wait according to
tony fauci
but bureaucrats at who's headquarters in
switzerland
need the cash and they need it now
i joined my fellow representatives in
thanking
the world health organization for its
role
in leading the global public health
response
to this pandemic and as such
i am honored to announce that the united
states
will remain a member of the world health
organization
what a malignant buffoon history will
indict his behavior
so you're still waiting for your
stimulus check the who's not waiting for
your money they're getting it
but it's not just wh o according to the
daily caller
the lab in wuhan where this pandemic
likely started the wuhan institute of
virology
will continue to receive american
taxpayer funding for the next several
years
it's hard to believe that's real it is
tony fauci himself has supported
research
at that lab it's enough to blow your
mind
again the people responsible for this
pandemic
aren't facing consequences instead
they're getting you as tax dollars
the consequences fall where they always
do
on the american middle class so if you
unleash a deadly virus on the world or
cause thousands of deaths in nursing
homes or fail to warn the world in order
to repeat your appease your masters in
china
you get millions but if you're just a
waitress in brooklyn dealing with the
fallout of all of this and you step out
of line for a moment
you're done the 34 year old says she was
fired after telling her employer she and
her husband are considering starting a
family
and she had hesitations about getting
the covid19 vaccine
do you think it's fair for a workplace
to be able to determine whether or not
its employees
should be vaccinated i don't
i don't um you know especially in a
situation
like mine i asked for a little more time
that's a
very legitimate reason
yeah this is someone who doesn't oppose
vaccines
who's thankful f for vaccines like most
americans but who simply has questions
that's the person who's suffering
is that fair no but it's happening
everywhere the people in charge of this
country your politicians your bosses the
public health experts especially bill
gates
all of a sudden they have more power
than they've ever had including over
your personal life
certainly over the lives of your
children they can't go outside or attend
class in many states right now
but don't worry it's for their own good
randy weingarten is the president of the
american federation of teachers that's
the second largest teachers union in the
country she's not a doctor she's not a
scientist she's a lawyer
but according to randy weingarten
medically speaking
your kids shouldn't be anywhere near a
school
is there a point in which kids have been
out of physical in-person school for so
long
that the education that they've lost
isn't really recoverable that the third
grade the fourth grade the kindergarten
they lost
you can they can take extra semesters in
the summer they can do
but it can't really be fixed no i don't
believe that
i believe that kids are resilient and
kids will recover really
randy weingarten how many kids do you
have kids are resilient they'll recover
yet another promise we've heard during
this pandemic get the vaccine
life will return to normal that wasn't
true why should we believe
any of this is true and who's going to
be held responsible for these lies